a prayer that's way more than just a
prayer a mysterious dragon too big for
this world house of the dragon is
heating up here's what you may have
missed in episode 2.
episode 2 begins with some gnarly images
of sea life cleaning the flesh off the
bodies of sailors who appear to have
washed ashore in the next scene a
furious cordless valarian bursts into a
small council meeting and says something
must be done about the stepstones the
free cities and the crab feeder four
ships have now been lost the last one
was flying my banner otto hightower's
solution is to pay off the families of
the victims and refund corliss for his
losses but the seastank doesn't think
this course of action goes far enough in
the premiere corliss speaks of the
triarchy and someone named cragus drayar
in episode 2 when corliss asks damon if
he's heard about the trouble in the
stepstones in an attempt to recruit him
into the war he wants damon replies that
he has heard something about some
mirrish prince crakas the crab feeder
and this prince are one in the same and
the triarchy is the free cities of lis
mir and tirosh the crab feeder came by
his nickname honestly feeding sailors to
the craps might seem like a metaphor for
sea warfare but cragus literally feeds
his victims to his namesakes by fixing
their bodies to stakes at low tide and
letting the crabs do their thing the
source material george rr martin's fire
and blood leaves more to the imagination
and simply explains that the name was
related to the inventive punishments he
inflicted upon his enemies
history buff king viserys is building or
at least commissioning an elaborate
model of valyria the home of the
targaryens and the other now extinct
dragon riding families a city of a
thousand years
and all that men had learned
the doom consumed it all alike and
neither of them turned during one of
their visits in episode 2 he explains
his project to the young lady who's
obviously been sent to seduce him
alison's hightower the daughter of the
hand of the king viserys waxes poetic
about how valyria was built into a
volcano like dragonstone so its people
could be close to the source of their
magic and power he tells of blood mages
and a civilization that was one thousand
dragons strong do you believe the
westeros can be another valyria of grace
the king answers that it depends on
whether she means valyria at its peak or
at its fall referring to the doom of
valyria though martin has not yet
written a definitive account of exactly
what happened valeria suffered some
apocalyptic event about a dozen years
after the targaryens fled thanks to the
prophetic vision of danis targaryen some
characters speak of the doom as if it
was an unavoidable natural disaster but
the strong implication is that the
valyrians brought collapse upon
themselves with their lust for magic and
power viserys considers his own kingdom
with 10 dragons already falling into
disrepair after 100 years the glory of
old valeria will never be seen again
maybe not the glory but perhaps the
hubris in ruin the ceres thinks ruling
over peace means throwing feasts in
turnies not making difficult but
necessary decisions meanwhile the seven
hells are about to break loose it's
incredibly symbolic when he drops and
breaks a dragon figurine and mistakes
alison's ambition for kindness when she
has it fixed for thousands of years the
valyrians were
the best in the world that almost
everything
then
and then they weren't
episode two makes it clear that
allison's hightower is a willing
participant and not just a pawn in the
schemes that revolve around her though
the nervous fingernail picking suggests
she certainly has mixed feelings the
main plot line revolves around alison
and her father otto's efforts to
convince rhaenyra that her father the
king should remarry and to make sure he
chooses the teenage alicent over the 12
year old laina valerian who's the better
candidate on paper to soften up her
bestie alison has to mediate the
reconciliation between rhaenyra and her
father who've barely spoken since her
mother and brother's traumatic deaths
step one alison takes her to the sept to
pray to the seven in an attempt to get
some closure about it the scene is much
more loaded with subtext and
foreshadowing than it might seem upon
first watch the hightowers are the lords
of old town where they were once the
richest and most powerful family in
westeros the faith of the seven the
predominant religion in westeros also
calls old town home and the two entities
are closely aligned the hightowers
support the faith and vice versa which
increases both the noble family and the
new religion's political influence in
contrast the targaryens have a tenuous
relationship with the seven publicly
they've converted but really they keep
to their ancient customs and do their
best to limit the seven's role in the
culture of westeros by getting rhaenyra
to bend the knee in prayer alison is
flexing her own strength and using the
religion to which she's theoretically
much more devoted than rhaenyra for
cynical purposes what do i say
whatever you wish
it's only for you in the gods to know
showrunners have promised that we'll see
at least 17 dragons throughout the run
of house of the dragon including at
least nine in the first season so far
we've gotten glimpses of rhaenyra's
elegant mount cyrax and damon's fierce
red steed karaxis also known as the
bloodworm we've also heard about
valerian the black dread whose skull now
rests in the cellars of the red keep and
dreamfire whose egg was chosen for
rhaenyra's brother then stolen by damon
on his walk with lena valerian the tween
princess asks the king what it was like
to ride valerian some backstory viserys
was the last of the targaryen kings to
ride the black dread and he never bonded
with or rode another dragon afterwards
that means it's been quite some time
since the king was on dragonback which
is itself a symbol of his supposed
weakness then laina inquires about vegar
who she says was too big for the dragon
pit viserys retorts that she was perhaps
too big for this world vegar was a
female dragon almost as large as
balerion who was ridden by one of king
aegon's sister wives visenya long story
short vegar the biggest dragon in the
world is still out there and no one
knows for sure where she's nesting this
conversation isn't just scene filler
veigar is basically chekhov's dragon
sure to show up at some critical moment
in the future
after king viserys slices his finger on
the iron throne in episode 1 we see in
episode two that what started out as a
small cut has rotted into a serious
health situation though it occurs at a
different point in the narrative in fire
and blood the ceres cuts his digit so
badly that it needs to be amputated the
incident scars him physically and
mentally so much so that in the book
king viserys never sits on the iron
throne again in house of the dragon the
maesters recommend maggots to eat away
at the gangrene both versions come to
the same metaphorical conclusion the
wound will not heal viserys himself
utters this exact phrase in another
context later in the episode
your mother's absence
is a wound that will never heal he adds
that in queen emma's absence the red
keep will never recover and he's right
had she lived viserys would have
remained married to her and probably
wouldn't have produced another heir
rhaenyra's claim would be absolute save
for damon's insolence at being passed
over with emma out of the picture king
viserys has to choose between two
factions one led by the hightowers and
one led by the valerians since neither
side will ever accept the promotion of
the other over their own interests civil
war is inevitable